In this segment, we justify some
of the property is that
the correlation coefficient
that we
claimed a little earlier.
The most important properties of
the correlation coefficient
lies between minus
1 and plus 1.
We will prove this property for
the special case where we
have random variables with zero
means and unit variances.
So standard deviations are also
1, so most of the terms
here disappear and the
correlation coefficient is
simply the expected value
of X times Y.
We will show that in this
special case the expected
value of X times Y lies
between minus 1 and 1.
But the proof of this fact
remains valid with a little
bit of more algebra along
similar lines
for the general case.
What we will do is we will
consider this quantity here
and expand this quadratic
and write it as
expected value of X squared.
Then there's a cross term,
which is minus 2 rho, the
expected value of X times Y,
plus rho squared, expected
value of Y squared.
Now since we assume that the
random variables have 0 mean,
this is the same as the variance
and we assume that
the variance is 1, so this
term here is equal to 1.
Now, the expected value of X
times Y is the same as the
correlation coefficient
in this case.
So we have minus 2 rho
squared and from
here we have rho squared.
And by the previous argument,
again this quantity, according
to our assumptions, is equal to
1 so we're left with this
expression, which is 1
minus rho squared.
Now, notice that this is the
expectation of a non-negative
random variable so this
quantity here must be
non-negative.
Therefore, 1 minus rho squared
is non-negative, which means
that rho squared is less
than or equal to 1.
And that's the same as requiring
that rho lie between
minus 1 and plus 1.
And so we have established this
important property, at
least for the special case of
0 means and unit variances.
But as I mentioned, it remains
valid more generally.
Now let us look at an extreme
case, when the absolute value
of rho is equal to 1.
What happens in this case?
In that case, this term is 0
and this implies that the
expected value of the square
of this random variable is
equal to 0.
Now here we have a non-negative
random variable,
and its expected value is 0,
which means that when we
calculate the expected value
of this there will be no
positive contributions and so
the only contributions must be
equal to 0.
This means that X minus rho Y
has to be equal to 0 with
probability 1.
So X is going to be equal to
rho times Y and this will
happen with essential
certainty.
Now also because the absolute
value overall is equal to 1,
this means that we have either
X equal to Y or X equals to
minus Y, in case rho is
equal to minus 1.
So we see that if the
correlation coefficient has an
absolute value of 1, then X
and Y are related to each
other according to a simple
linear relation, and it's an
extreme form of dependence
between
the two random variables.